this video contains spoilers for better
call saul through season 6 episode 5. if
you're interested in this great
character who only really has one
problem but you haven't watched that far
yet then this isn't the video you're
looking for
there was a point in season four a
better call saw where if i'm being
honest i struggled to care what was
going on with the story about gus
building his super lab i knew it would
eventually get completed i knew that gus
and mike would both survive the series
and i knew that none of the germans
involved would play a significant role
in breaking bad more than that it felt
like the whole cartel side of the story
needed something to make it feel vital
because it was drifting away from the
main story about jimmy mcgill sure mike
needed to continue his descent to become
the guy we knew him to be in the
original series but the writers had the
problem of working against the nature of
the show since it's a prequel they met
this challenge by introducing a new
character from the salamanca family that
pesky brood of characters who all sort
of have that person you hope you never
find yourself mixed up with temperament
about them eduardo salamanca aka lalo
was a nephew of hector that was
previously unknown and a cousin to tuco
marco and leonel his name was first
mentioned in that much-discussed
throwaway line in the desert from saul
goodman's first episode that also gave
us nacho jimmy's fear there hinted that
their paths would eventually cross and
that he must be a pretty imposing
character to still be on his mind 4
years later that is not terribly
surprising the salamancas all have that
going for them they manage to be great
antagonists despite the fact that
they're a bit one-dimensional with that
one dimension being they're unstable and
potentially violent it was clear from
his very first scene that lalo stood out
from the other members in that regard
when nacho found him cooking in the
kitchen of the restaurant the family
runs their drug business out of i didn't
know he was related until he said it out
loud he was cooking like we'd seen tuko
do before but it came off as the type of
guy you wanted to get to know better
rather than generally making your skin
crawl of course in the next episode he
cleared up any confusion that he might
just be a black sheep when he murdered
an absolutely innocent clerk at travel
travelwire while following mike he
exposed himself as a cold-blooded killer
leaving no room for debate the show
knows how captivating tony dalton can be
in this role and seem to balance that
out by having him periodically do
something that reminds us of his
brutality in case we might forget it's
part of what makes it work he's
fascinating because of this capacity to
be more than one thing at the same time
it's the perfect mixture of charm and
menace that makes you warm up to him in
every scene while fearing what he might
do next he's absolutely dastardly but
has a few redeeming things mixed in
there to keep it interesting he appeared
to care about the people at his compound
and even though he didn't have a problem
killing his body double matteo the look
on his face before that happened
indicated that he didn't enjoy it
although there wasn't much to say he had
remorse beyond that and the scene where
he noticed the family of fred from
travelwire in the courtroom without
skipping a beat seems to back that up he
breathed life back into the cartel side
of things by being a worthy adversary
for gus and by hiring jimmy as his
lawyer he solved the problem of the two
different stories drifting apart he
matches up well with both of these
characters gus isn't able to outmaneuver
him and jimmy isn't able to out talk him
he's a nearly perfect character that
even this late in the story integrates
seamlessly he's a fan favorite that only
seems to get better and the only problem
there is is that lalo salamanca must die
i say must because i don't see any way
around it he has to go down and it has
to happen before the end of this season
of course it's always possible that the
show could swerve hard into new
territory but even then something fairly
contrived would have to happen i mean
could lola get hit on the head in
germany and wake up with amnesia in the
hospital under an assumed identity
technically yes but that doesn't feel
like the show we've been watching plus
they've been leaning in hard to the
effect that his being out there in the
world is having on gus the chicken man
who is usually composed and calculated
is currently falling apart so how would
you explain his getting it together if
this threat were still out there i've
seen a lot of comments asking if he can
make it out of the series alive could he
show up in the gene timeline could he
just generally outlive everyone but i
don't really see a path to that i think
some of this comes from the fact that
jimmy was still afraid of him in that
scene in the desert the counter-argument
to that is what gus says to hector when
he goes to gloat about killing the
cartel during the breaking bad timeline
he tells him that jesse killed the only
other salamanca who was left alive his
grandson joaquin and says that the
salamanca name will die with hector
which basically completes his revenge
arc and he looks absolutely certain that
it's the truth the gus and better call
saul season 6 wouldn't be able to make
that claim also none of the cartel stuff
from the original series makes sense if
lalo is still out there somewhere bolsa
and eladio would have to still think
he's dead and hector would just have to
be there not knowing what happened to
him after he found out he was alive with
his ending nacho provided cover for
everything to make sense as long as lalo
doesn't re-emerge he's already faked his
death once and gus didn't actually
believe it and things seem to be setting
up for a final confrontation which we
know he can't win so in my mind the
question is not if lalo will die it's
when i suppose if you wanted to nitpick
the character he can be borderline
superhero-ish and that is something that
pops up every now and again when he
escapes out a two-story window or
something along those lines but in light
of the situation that sort of works in
the favor of the upcoming conclusion in
order to defeat him gus will have to
outdo himself and that should make for a
memorable ending there's also the
possibility that he could bring more
about mr frink to light in the process
and that means he could have a lasting
influence on the story after he's gone
lalo is dashing he's dynamic he's been a
great addition to this late part of the
series and he's gonna have to get out of
the way so the story can move on and i
think that is a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments how
you think his story might end right now
it all feels like it's heading towards a
showdown in the super lab but do you
think there's room for a twist does
nachos ending playing out exactly how it
should have make you suspicious do you
think that they'll go a different
direction here or do you think it's just
going to be a fascinating showdown where
one menacing character out does the
other please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon